we are excited and honored to have
professor Stephen carpenter with us and
this is the first of a series of events
on Larry Susskind on the faculty and
urban studies and planning it's
interesting to me that several people
here have a water interest several
people here of planning interest several
people here have artistic or arts
methods interest several people here
have sort of public education interest
and and all of those are alive and well
in the department of urban studies and
planning in different kinds of ways
there is an environmental group in the
department that I have had some
responsibility for and water is
concerned within the environmental group
not just domestically but
internationally which relates to part of
your work we're interested in water as
environmental justice concern not just a
natural resource management concern and
so when I first learned of some of the
ways in which your work is focused on
making clean water available to people
in different places there was a direct
connection with that aspect of of what
we do I was really interested in how
issues of race could be raised in a way
the conversation was possible and that
is another very big part of what our
department and our school are interested
in so by way of background those are
some of the thematic interests that led
us to very much want you to be here well
thanks Larry
as far back as I can remember I like
making stuff I'll just make things you
know I'm the oldest of four boys and the
oldest and the youngest were born five
and a half years apart no twins so we
were constantly together in doing things
and we make
like a set of golf clubs my dad had golf
clubs we weren't allowed to use them so
we made them of course we used his
copper pipe for the the plumbing in the
house and so making things was always
part of what what I did and and have
done and just engaging the one his
shifts and has moved my backgrounds
really pottery his really ceramics
touching the clay touching the mud
making things that's my degree is in
ceramics and fine art I don't know what
it was this urge ability interest for
teaching for education so that
complicated the situation making stuff
and teaching stuff but actually you can
do that that's called being an art
educator or a teacher and the ceramics
piece stayed with I couldn't shake the
clay couldn't get the clay out of my
fingernails the making of things had to
always be there and I taught elementary
school art that was the art teacher in
elementary school and that was among the
most invigorating experiences of my life
because the students are always about
making something their bodies are always
moving they're constantly in a state of
absorbing what they're doing in the
world and seeing other people doing and
moving and checking and so that energy
was was quite interesting to me followed
that experience up with a doctoral
degree in art education but the idea was
that the making and the teaching and the
learning and the asking of questions
through art through the visual imagery
that you're talking about that was what
was so important and you mentioned the
notion of access
well we didn't have golf clubs we didn't
have access to with like we saw we
didn't have access to so making our own
access i'm interested in that as well
how does one make one's own access so
moving around to a series of different
universities as an art educator still
making part of my graduate both graduate
degrees was about being in the clay
studio as much as it was being in the
seminar room and that was really the
focus of my dissertation was in the clay
studio we were talking and critiquing
about color and shape and form and how
the glaze works and on the other side of
the same part of campus on the other
side of the road in the theory class as
an art education we're talking about
postmodern theory and feminist theory
and film theory and
interpreting installations and and and
performances and then on the other side
of the road I'd go to my class the next
day we were again critiquing but we were
talking about oh I like I like that
handle show me how you made the handle
this handle works and that one doesn't
we never defined what works meant but
putting those together the making and
that interpreting and thinking and
theorizing in both registers doesn't
have to be separated so to think of us
even with labels I find kind of curious
like we have to find a place on campus
but the understanding that we can move
in and out of those spaces and we can
start to shed those those identities the
kind of group that has self-assembled
today speaks to multiple interests that
I have and trying to weave it into what
is an art education how does one learn
through the making of things through the
to the display of cultural products
through cultural production what kind of
questions can we ask not just about what
someone else has made but what kind of
questions can we ask through them the
act of making itself we can make meaning
through relationships we can make
meaning through conversation we can make
meaning through verbal or written
responses so it's the the making of
meaning making of cultural product
making of a difference right so this
notion of making doesn't have to always
have this physicality to it from saying
all that to say that the clay left my
fingernails for a while until move to
Texas my wife is an engineer mechanical
engineer material science and it's a
great opportunity for her to move there
for me there's no art education there at
all they got my CV and didn't know where
to put me send it all over campus and
finally the education folks at all will
take him
it has education in his degree will take
him telling you all that to say I got to
Texas and art education had to be I had
to reinvent it or at least I had to
figure out what I meant by it and how I
fit in if you don't have an art
department how do you have art education
well you just open the studio in your
garage and have people over on Fridays I
did that or you can engage in the work
in the curriculum that fixed set of
notions and premeditated concepts terms
practices skills construct that
educational experience my entrance into
a more curriculum instruction space was
through my background as an artist and
as an art educator the water filter work
that I do and have started to do came
about when I was in Texas I met a guy
who is name is Oscar muñoz Oscar is in
charge of the Texas A&M colonias
programs all along the border
Texas is 1/3 the width of the United
States so that distance and then 150
miles up is called the border of Texas
and in that space they live over half a
million people most of whom don't have
access to clean water in their homes and
Oscar talk you know let me know this and
he works with communities all across
that swath and as an art educator that
was interesting to me because I had to
learn about a lot of the practices that
that he's up against and faces telling
you all it is to say I'm not that I I
planned where this has got where my my
work has gone but it it's always my grad
always moved and shifted to new it's
almost like water water finds its own
level right water fills the this the the
vessel in which it's poured but I've
never lost the clay I've never lost that
notion of making or the ways that
meanings can be made and understandings
can be constructed through engagement
with other people that's what education
is it's a social space teaching and
learning is a social space aren't
education can take up and take on those
those tasks as well the title for this
visit that people have seen and that you
gave us is making something from nothing
and first of all sort of there's
immediately doubt about whether you can
actually make I mean you can transform
things but the notion that you can make
something out of nothing would sort of
defy most of the laws of physics
presumably and so you mean something by
that and then appropriate technology as
intentionally disruptive
responsibilities
yeah that is a mouthful that title isn't
I actually had a lot of trouble with it
[Laughter]
to the left of the colon making
something from nothing
that piece was intentionally provocative
right I mean you kind of have to do that
in some ways to entice folks to show up
to certain things maybe but the idea of
making of course you know defying laws
of physics yeah I'm with you so no you
know knowing that there's a problem with
with that if we think of it in certain
realms the idea that there are some
folks who don't necessarily have access
it's about access maybe it should have
said you know making something from
whatever it is that you have right but
if we move it to nothing you start to
think well there's a there's a there's a
complete and utter lack of something
for example there's some people who have
no access to clean water we can raise a
bit of hyperbole there and say they
don't have access or they have nothing
there folks you know who we talk about
food scarcity we talk about folks who
homeless folks who need shelter I mean
so you can take minimum and exaggerate
it just a little bit more right it was
something called artistic license let's
let's use that and turn it into nothing
so making something from nothing what
can we make from what is available to us
so that's the something from nothing and
in in the case of this first visit but
something is adequate access to clean
water and then nothing is the lack of
that and the something is a response
which would in this case is a ceramic
water filter made out of clay and
sawdust the nothing is well that's just
clay it's it's just in the riverbed
that's that's nothing or let's just
sawdust that's leftover scraps then
that's nothing right you see you
understand that play that's going there
appropriate technology is essentially
whatever is available culturally and
locally that fits in with this within
the cultural practices of of a community
introducing an external or an unfamiliar
substance or chemical or food is not
appropriate to certain community because
it's either against one's religion it's
against one's history against one's
culture it
doesn't fit in so finding something
that's appropriate for example clay is
essentially a material that is
accessible to almost every single
culture in the history of this of the
world and clay is a natural naturally
occurring material in most places around
the world in some places using plastic
oh that doesn't seem to make sense or
appropriate technology is using what is
that hand philosopher theorist Umberto
Eco he was a guy who knew everything but
he didn't know it echo had numerous
theories among them where these in
theory of intentions he says that the
artist or the author has an intention
and the viewer or the reader has an
intention but he also says the work has
an intention that comes about through
the rest process or a series of events
but this idea of having an intention
means it's deliberate so I'm interested
in in in thinking about why we're doing
what we're doing that's that's where
that intentional piece disruptive you
know if I pick this up and I threw this
water at the camera that would be
disruptive in a number of rays or if
you're in a you know in a quiet library
and a stampede of aardvarks comes
through the space that's disruption
right so we understand disruption is
something that is abnormal or not
expected within a particular context
that has assumed rules regulations and
ways of being but I'm also thinking of a
disruption in the intentional sense of
to reveal or to poke at or to engage or
to entice a certain kind of conversation
or relationship and that kind of
conversation relationship is the
responsibility would you agree that most
educational efforts are disruptions
aimed at fulfilling a responsibility
that is defining education that way I
don't think enough of them are oh you
think they should be I think they should
I like to shift that up and question
that and then there's there's it's it's
very difficult to to get at new ways of
doing something without disrupting a
status quo without without questioning
it we say it's because we're responsible
and we have to disrupt but what about
the choice of the people and the place
whose lives you're disrupting is that
fair to them sure yeah no certainly the
way you frame it it's not fair to them
but in the disruption of the lives of
the communities that are mentioned in
Texas it's not disrupting uninvited
it's an invited disruption and second
the disruption has to do with whatever
the current practice was new was not
fulfilling or were responding to needs
of the community in in their eyes and in
you know to my eyes as well so my friend
as I mentioned Oscar who for years has
been working in throughout South Texas
when he learned to the work I was that I
was you know at that point still
learning how to do he said oh there's
there's a water issue would you come
down and work with us we talked to us
let's see if this would work out that
was my invitation to come in Oscar was
already part of that community I would
never imagine just driving down there
driving to any community and say hey
Dyke if something you need I'm gonna
sell you something that's not my
approach and so that kind of disruption
I think is on the the unethical side he
was a bit wary of someone coming in and
he's shared and other people have shared
stories with me of researchers going
into communities oh yeah I have this
ideas let me study what you're doing let
me work with you and they take the
information and there's a report that's
promised and the report never gets back
to the communities or the results never
never help and he said he has never he
had never seen a report come back based
on the invitations to the scholars and
so once we got to know each other he
felt comfortable with me so but then he
had to go through a process of talking
with members of the community to say hey
here's you know have this friend coming
down that's the invitation is the
invitation pieces so what is an
invitation have to consist of for you to
be of a sort that you're comfortable
then responding in this rich disruptive
way you need a vote of the community has
to be 100 percent majority rule people
you like say come on down
what what is in your mind about what
legitimizes these kinds of disruptions
again it has to be that imitation from
someone who is positioned within the
community then there has to be for me a
conversation and and so no the entire
community because defining who is in the
community is often difficult to do
anyway
certainly it's it's often just a leader
or some member of the community who
might want to engage a conversation that
that then might expand in their own
circles in this particular case in Texas
through my colleague we met with a few
leaders people who had worked within the
communities as promotoras as community
educators and and other senior members
of the community
a senior meeting they had been doing
work at the community centers and it was
let's just talk let's see where the
conversation goes very much like what
we're doing here having having a
conversation now it's not my role or
position or personality or interest to
push that after that conversation that's
on that's on whomever to to take that up
so when I speak of community it's it's
it's not the entirety there's not a
simple answer in this we all struggle
with this notion of the artist as the
independent thinker as a creator of
something that's an expression of an
individual view when you're calling this
a form of art education but isn't it
contrary to artists being artists how
was it art yeah so that's not a small
question but it's a very important
question it's a central question that
I'm still answering for myself but there
are three realms here one is the work in
South Texas that I actually wouldn't
call that art or art education okay
second is the kind of work that I will
do tomorrow the performance and that
moves into the realm of the social
practice and that's where I've I've come
to an agreement understanding
comfortable place with myself that
that's where the art education happened
and then this there's a third piece your
definition of an artist and what an
artist does that I want to disrupt down
in South Texas that kind of work for me
is not art education it certainly uses
an employ certain artistic practices
folks who have access to a kiln know how
to fire kiln and have access to clay
that's where you want to begin your work
usually that's the the tile person or
the the pot putter or it's the brick
maker but my collaboration and myung
involvement in that project I wouldn't
call that art that was kind of me shed
you know that that helps to clarify that
piece of it so the work that I'm going
to do I will do tomorrow I'm gonna set
up a water filter production facility in
one of the rooms downstairs and I'm
gonna make water filters the idea there
is to engage in a practice that somehow
blurs what might be our conventional
notions of art making art practice with
practices from other disciplines we're
not quite sure where one ends and one
begins and it's supposed to remain in
that uncomfortable space if one is
thinking in that social practice art as
social practice register if you can set
up that practice as an engagement as an
ongoing set of activities where people
can come in and out of that space
there's an educational component
invariably there'll be a question hey
man what are you doing that's an
invitation right there for me to respond
so we can establish this conversation as
a relationship you're not creating art
you're creating something that serves a
function in response to the need of a
client you're saying though it's not art
I'm an artist and it's my social
practice that you should observe here is
art education but the product of my
artwork is not art it's more than the
filter itself that filter is just one
component of the work the work being the
performance education as experience this
notion of experience is where the
education happens for some of us the
next step is oh and I want to help a
place in Africa or Latin America in a
community make a factory
where there are people now without me
they're capable of making more filters
and maybe they can sell them for a small
amount to be able to maintain them a
community business the doing of all of
that that seems to be a different realm
it is yeah and I have not worked closely
with communities as you're saying to set
up facilities although and in South
Texas I did I helped laid the groundwork
and that facilities is working you saw
pictures right but there are a number of
groups who are doing the exact kind of
work that you're mentioning and it's not
from an arts or an art education
perspective it is from that social
entrepreneur realm that you're that
you're talking about and I am very
supportive of that piece and that is
actually an intriguing component of what
comes out of this this work it's that
work that then has benefits in terms of
health economics self-sustaining
capacity that that I find intriguing and
it's something that can be attempted
where it's not intended to be a
moneymaker initially it's intended to to
save people's lives and and and to
respond in that way so I'm curious about
the longer term with this community in
South Texas that you're working with
obviously it sounds like there's a
really pressing need so these water
filters can meet that immediate need is
the long-term goal still to kind of get
a more traditional grid water setup for
them yeah yes the origin of the filters
was that they were supposed to be a
first response to natural disaster and
they were not supposed to be long-term
their point of views temporary solutions
unfortunately for some folks around the
world these become more long-term
responses what do you do when you're
just starting out what's your advice for
how you go about getting
that's a tough one I think sometimes
it's it's not about poking for the
invitation initially sometimes you find
ways to to become part of the community
it's some level that might sound like oh
but you're really kind of manipulating
right because in the back of your mind
you're saying okay at the right moment
I'm gonna spring the question I'm gonna
get the invitation that's not what I'm
talking about what I'm talking about is
being part of a community in doing the
work in the community where the work
that you're doing might be seen by folks
who could invite you again that sounds
like it's you some sort of nefarious
manipulative component but not really I
mean I think it's about continuing your
work and staying visible and the
invitations come there's a approach
called arts entrepreneurship that is
gaining traction in several universities
have courses in art entrepreneurship
arts entrepreneurship and minors and I
think a few are starting majors as well
or have majors because these other
groups are doing this kind of work folks
know about the water filter technology
is starting to take off and people are
collaborating they're entering into that
space and what they're doing is they're
they're making available for their
learners k-12 learners possibilities
that they might not have thought it's
the curriculum work that I'm doing with
with teachers I think that it becomes
quite engaging great thank you all very
much you very much yeah yeah I hope to
see you tomorrow thank you thank you